altana 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 1
der prozess geht es um herzlich
willkommen zu einer runde heimsieg in
der wir heute ein ganz besonderes thema
getragen werden und zwar wird sich alles
um den sommer drehen denn es wird echt
schon heiß heiß bei uns zumindest darauf
von euch tun
okay okay ich mache ich mache es einfach
mal die tore des siegers direkt neviges
bond alte grass lässt ist direkt neben
dem sport alter zwei blöcke neben mir
besser fertig bekommt das geilste ist
ich weiter ich war noch auf dem hof blog
das heißt ich komme ich denke alter ich
bin politiker die sie mich nicht wie du
um die sind begeistert aber noch mit
zahlen sagen weil ich gerade aus also
bei mir ich war ja relativ weit im süden
ist es ist schon richtig geil und zwar
so megamäßig sommer geil
ungefähr 30 grad von den ganzen firma
und in deinem gehirn ist auch noch
besser temperatur bei uns in berlin
habe ich früh ins auto gesetzt wohl nur
dass logan tierisch war also fenster und
da los sei das war wirklich extrem die
hitze staut sich so was von im auto war
heute früh die alle 30 riesige hat ja
okay ich kenne ein bisschen chillen und
anspornt de sica einfach direkt neben
mir vor knapp 45 grad weil ich habe mir
von meinem youtube man eine dicke villa
auf gran canaria 9 cm bizeps nicht sagen
ich kann ich gerade meine eigenen alltag
drei leute schockiert als sie richtig ja
ich habe mich nicht verarschen davon
auch warum mag ich den boden da war
sogar ein von anders wollen lässt sich
fünf gewesen
55 wenn die magische 50 13 sekunden noch
nie gewinnen
doch letztlich als achter noch the frog
kreistag auch ziemlich groß ja über der
com ist es schwer zu spielen als sieger
verstecken
echt so lang noch leute die kunden nicht
sekunden lesen mittels doch aber ich
habe zu der schon vorbei
ich kann die eu nicht lesen ist nicht
nur als ich weiß ich bei mir sind jetzt
glaube ich so 15 grad oder so aber ich
glaube ich dass dieser sommer ja 15
nicht mehr perfekt 18
aber ich glaube dieser sommer wird
richtig brutal ich geh jetz auch gleich
ins wasser und lässt dann noch paar
texte für aber ich glaube diese sommer
mit bibel heißt ihr könnt ihr auch in
die kommentare schreiben
wie es bei euch heute gerade aussieht am
samstag heute samstag und mahnschreiben
ob es jetzt zu besonders heiß ist bei
euch und vor allem auch ja ob ihr euch
auf den sommer freut weil du weißt ja
immer eine recht geile zeit genau und
bei mir könnte das ganze dann für
sonntag mal machen interessiert mich
persönlich auch weil ich das nämlich am
sonntag buchladen werde egal wir machen
einfach von hinten dran und wir sind
gleich wieder
war das immer wieder und ich weiß gar
nicht ob es ethisch außer oder für die
behinderten den verkehr
aber ich hoffe ich bekomme world blog
hervor nein ach nee wüste gobi wall ich
sehe einfach aus wie thaddeus aus und
schreibt mit in der gallenstein nase
wieder ins wasser gehen deshalb funktion
immer so
was willst du denn apple bestimmt
ich weiß nicht wie das ausrichten ich
kann das überhaupt nicht vorstellen
weiter ihre koppel wall alles dummes
hier kann man auch nicht weg ich bin bei
dieser mit windmühle bei dem kornfeld
ich weiß jetzt richtig aus was ist mit
den arbeitslos alter weil dieser dieser
nächste kongress der größte pizza fand
einfach um mal eine heilung in caps
geschrieben hat diese video zu wissen
was gerade los ist was lockt ist das was
vom zu wissen aber okay was ist das für
ein blog bitte beim stamm
ach so ja du hast du weißt was ich bin
ich bin
warum soll ich da nein ich finde dich
du wirst niemals finden mein hund
springt die aufnahme läuft bei dem hund
eingefunden kommen ganz kalt ganz kalt
ganz genau richtig nicht geklappt es
weiter ich bin doch comp-mall mein
lieber ich habe getötet
du musst nicht flüstern die höheren dich
nicht ich weiß wie ich das überleben
soll
geboxt
ja ja ich weiß
ich habe erstmal für liegestütze bist du
das nein ich bin keiner ist von euch es
bei mir doch jetzt oder nein nein nein
9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2
ja ja das war ungefähr die spannendsten
sie könnte die ich jemals gespielt
klaus borger ja wirklich gefallen hat
das den daumen nach oben da falls ihr
über die vorschläge habt kritik dann
schreibt es in die kommentare
nämlich immer gerne auf
und ja da würde ich sagen hat einen
schönen tag kommt rein und schau